hey guess what
let's serve up some news sunny side up
if you like to sleep naked as the day
you were born apparently the writers at
newsweek want you to go for it they
talked to a bunch of sleep scientists
and psychologists and collected every
single reason that you should
sleep start naked here are just a few
sleeping nude helps you fall asleep
faster
a cooler sleep temperature leads to a
deeper non-rem
um sleep for more restorative sleep
um and it can even help with male
fertility oh and vaginal health oh my
goodness what all of a sudden we went
goop on them
i know
hey guess what
did you hear the news
newsweek is real hot to trot on this
subject ross thoughts i have so many
thoughts right now
i'll tell you i don't sleep in the nude
um it's not for me um
no
i
i have what do you sleep in i don't know
pajamas not silk pajamas no i pictured
you on something no don't picture me at
all
our first story today is about some
kindred spirits of yours a couple of
road trippers from the uk
fox news reports that shannon orr and
ian cameron drove across scotland's
north coast not by van not by rv
but by hearse
nice a converted hearse they called the
grim sleeper
it's got a bed in the back plenty of
room for their pups billy and peanut
maybe charlie couldn't hang out tom is
this a vehicle to die for or what sounds
good sounds good lots of space lots of
space
it's made for lying down
for long periods of time right ross
could you
ride around in a hurry not for a single
moment thank you very much no i mean
it could be a killer ride but it's not
for me i'm i'm made for a winnebago this
is a winnipeg no
i don't i mean good for people for being
having ingenuity but enjoy your ride
but
it's the year 2051
and we're thriving yeah but i will say
that i noticed there still are no flying
cars which makes me furious weren't we
promised flying cars in the future yeah
that's what the movies would have let us
think
well it is time for drew's news of the
future where things are looking up first
in future green news
[Music]
we did it wind and solar power have
saved the planet that's right
climate change has been reversed thanks
to lots of different alternative sources
of energy plus the invention of the
perfectly cloned meat which reduced
global greenhouse gas emissions
significantly and in a blind i know
[Applause]
businesses are barely keeping up with
all the halloween spirit fortune reports
that retailers have been selling out of
all things spooky inflatable gravestones
gigantic 12 foot skeletons and the
hottest halloween decoration item on
tiktok right now it's got like
six million views is something it's a
ghost rug what yeah a ghost drug look at
this
this is what everybody wants they're
sold out everywhere drew are you gonna
incorporate one of these i i mean i
don't think i can because you cannot get
that that's exactly what i was just
gonna say good luck getting one because
they are out they are out out out you
know what i a lot i'm a very festive
person but i'm also a very practical
person so for each holiday i give myself
one container like plastic storage bin
of decor because i'm sorry this rug is
cute but where are gonna go the other 11
months of the year
the washington post reports that mark
and rachel both called an uber pool on
halloween night a few years ago rachel
got in dressed as a dalmatian and
immediately hit it off with mark who was
dressed as mark
four years later they just got married
oh
my god
the only thing i found in an uber were
some free mints and a weird stain that i
really wanted to attack
but
how hopeful is this yes this is you
never know where this person could be
you can be in traffic and then find
yourself doing a little bumper-to-bumper
later if you know what i mean
i love love we dork out about it all the
time and i know that you have a wedding
coming up not your own but you're
officiating bob harper's wedding yeah
next year he asked me i get it i get to
wear tom ford suit oh oh i know uh-huh
um i'm very excited about it i have my
little packet
i will be rev rey rev grey the reverend
yeah that'd be really fun
for today's little yellow book we've got
some brand new music that's 41 years in
the making rossy it's about time well
abba is back hey yeah
and their brand new album called voyage
comes out next week and the album is
already
breaking records it sold 80 000 copies
in the first three days making it the
biggest pre-sale ever for universal
music in the uk
congratulations to abba what's your
favorite song um i mean fernando
waterloo dancing queen take a chance
take a chance it's great
i'm so excited about this yeah because
it sounds like them and we need
thank you
[Music]
you